and i predict at the end of 2028 when  you leave office second term the whole  country's gonna love you  they're gonna figure it out  they're just afraid of him because he's  bringing back the principles that this  country was founded upon and if our  founding fathers were here today  they would be trump republicans  that's a lie  i can see it right now mr president  george washington crossing the delaware  oh my god with a make america great flag  at the back of the boat as gross and  teddy roosevelt would have roosevelt  would have rosa ball make america great  cowboy hat  we love you we're so thankful that  you're here in arizona and when i'm  elected we will finish your big  beautiful wall  that's the the wall there will not be a  wall built whether trump is president or  not across the entire border in the next  seven years no matter what